hey guys Luke here at the altar boys
YouTube channel and today I'm going to
show you an awesome food that just
falling out of the sky
[Music]
these little green fruit are black
walnuts they are all over here in North
America especially here on the East
Coast and they taste magnificent they
have much more flavor than the
store-bought walnuts which are generally
English walnuts and I'm going to show
you how to gather these husk them pair
them we're gonna make a whole bunch of
good stuff with them every year we love
cooking with our walnuts check it out
these things are everywhere here at this
park just tons of them this is the nut
gather from weasel it's a tool for
picking up nuts pinecone fruit whatever
anything hard and round that you want to
pick up off your lawn this will do it
really easy this is the large model I'll
put a link in the description where you
can get one of these
[Music]
here we go babe just push that black
walnuts they fall from the tree they can
be really hard and green or they can be
black and mushy and full of maggots and
it really doesn't matter the nut inside
is still good but the blacker and gooey
are they are the more likely they are to
stay in your hands you can see there's
this black tar like that and it'll stain
your hands it's like tobacco spit
there's just kind of gross stuff but the
nut inside still very much good and
tasty
well I've filled up about four bins full
of walnuts and that's about 1/3 of the
nuts that are underneath this tree
when it comes to husking wallets there's
a lot of different ways to do it you can
stomp on them and squish them out of the
husk with your foot you can run them
over with the car you can rub them on
concrete but I have about 100 gallons of
wallets here that's a couple hundred
pounds at least and I need to do it a
little bit faster a little bit more
efficient so I have this pretty beefy
drill with a 36 inch long grout mixing
bit I didn't have the bit so I bought it
for about 10 bucks on amazon.com and
this is a 55 gallon trash can it's
pretty clean but you can use a drum or
whatever it doesn't have to be food
grade because you're not going to be
eating anything that's touching the drum
this is just to get the husks off now
we're going to fill this up with water I
have the wallets floating enough where
they can mix about and you can see how
black this water is so it'll stain
everything so I'm wearing gloves and old
clothes okay
the longer you do it the fewer floaters
you end up having and it turns the water
into this thick slurry after about four
or five minutes 95% of the husks have
been knocked off the shells and the
husks have been turned into this really
fine pulp and I've got this wonderful
organic spray-on tan now
[Music]
[Music]
so I've got this half-inch hardware
cloth and I just made a big pouch out of
it with zip ties and I'm just pouring
the walnut slurry in here and sifting
out the nuts well normally I'd use a 1
inch mesh to screen out the husk bits
from the nuts but I had half-inch lying
around that's what I used and
consequently I've got a lot more bits of
husk mixed in with my nuts that I
normally do I'm going to see if I can't
separate the nuts from the husks using
my driveway here I've got the two hoses
that I've spread out to make kind of
like bumper bowling here and I'm gonna
pour the nuts here and see if I can't
get them to roll down the driveway and
the husks to stay put also that will let
me spread them out and dry them which is
something I need to do before I store
them anyways so let's give that a go
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right well there we go we've got all
of our walnuts separated from the husks
and spread out on the driveway we'll let
it dry a little bit and then we'll store
them that's about a hundred pounds of d
husk wall that's right there I didn't
get a chance to dry them thoroughly on
the driveway before it started raining
so I put them in the trash can brought
them into the garage now I'm gonna
spread them out on the floor of my
garage and hopefully we can get them to
dry out in the next couple days
got all the walnuts spread out the box
fan on it hopefully they'll dry out the
next couple days
a few random with a hockey stick just
kind of using it here we go guys
the fruits of my labors each of these
bags are between 25 to 30 pounds plus I
had about 12 pounds of leftovers so that
puts this at about a 110 to 120 pounds
of walnuts now if you buy whole raw
organic walnuts at the store in shell
there are about five to ten dollars a
pound so this puts this between 550 to
1100 dollars worth of walnuts right here
which I got for free my local park so
that's kind of cool these will last a
very long time if you keep them with
these mesh bags in a cool dry place
they'll last years and taste absolutely
fabulous in the shelf
once you remove them from the shell they
will go rancid of comparatively quickly
they'll last months if you put them in a
refrigerator in the sealed bag the last
weeks if you leave them out on the
counter I just kind of put these in the
basement storm in the crawl space and
take them out and sell a few of them at
a time when I want to make a batch of
cookies or something now I'm going to
show you guys how to shell these and how
to cook with them it takes a little bit
more effort to crack open a black walnut
than it does in English walnut so get
yourself something hard and a small
hammer
[Music]
[Music]
you take that a little bit out and then
I'll open up the shelf somewhere there
you go that's the meat from about ten
wallets that was frustrating but it
gives me another chance to show you an
alternative method for cracking walnuts
the normal nut crackers you see at
Christmas aren't tough enough to crack a
black walnut so you need a specially
designed black walnut cracker well let's
have a pointy end and a flat end and you
put the flat end down pointy side up the
advantages of using a cracker is that it
tends not to pulverize the meat but it's
still a lot of work these crackers
really reduce the amount of time it
takes to remove the meat from the shell
and it greatly reduces the number of
shell bits that end up mixed in with
your meat all in all having a cracker
makes us go about three to four times
faster there's a few companies that
still make these black walnut crackers
and I'll put some links in the
description but I got this one off of
ebay it's an antique one I find the old
ones work the best and they're about the
same price there you go that's what the
walnut meat looks like when you get it
out intact that never happens when
you're using a hammer
well I only took a few minutes and I got
a lot of walnuts cracked and I'm gonna
take this ball into the kitchen and
separate out the remaining meat and
shells okay
all right there we go got about 3/4 cups
of shelled walnuts or about a pound all
right let's go make some cookies out of
these those black walnuts have such a
unique and powerful flavor tool makes it
absolutely worth all the extra work but
I hope you guys enjoyed this video hope
you learned something new if you want to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys youtube channel including a bunch
of outdoor cooking and foraging videos
check out the links in the descriptions
and don't forget to click Subscribe who
put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like that
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning
and hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching